Life.
What is it?
As a geneticist, I would
point you towards
this molecule, DNA.
Watson and Crick called it the
secret of life, and that's
because this molecule
has the ability to
make copies of itself.
And these copies get passed from
generation to generation.
And this has been happening
since the origins of life.
Every living thing has DNA.
The extraordinary diversity of
life that we see around us
comes from the fact that
different organisms have
slightly different versions
of the DNA molecule.
In the case of humans, our DNA
codes for about 22,000 genes,
and these genes are organised
onto chromosomes.
The human genome contains 23
pairs of chromosomes plus the
mitochondrial DNA.
And throughout this series,
we'll be featuring a new video
every day looking at each
of these one by one.
[BIRD CHIRPING]
So if we imagine for a moment
that these are some human
chromosomes, then Chromosome
One is the biggest one.
Human Chromosome One contains
about 2,000 genes, and these
are arranged along
the chromosome.
So you're going to have some
bits that are packed with
loads of genes and might have
some big gaps in between.
But these are all along
the chromosome.
And these genes do
different jobs.
For example, one of the genes
on Chromosome One is a gene
for the amylase enzyme,
which digests starch.
And amylase is in your saliva.
And different genes along the
chromosome have different jobs
to do and different times and
places when they should be
doing them.
So you have genes involved in
digestion, you've got genes
involved in growth and heart
muscles and all of these
different functions
in your body.
And one thing that the
chromosome structure does is
it doesn't lie there
in a straight line.
It's actually looped around
like spaghetti.
And you have some genes that are
hidden in this structure,
and they are not active, and
other ones that are turned on.
And so the chromosome structure
helps the right
genes be turned on in the
right time and place.
But there's something else as
well that the chromosome
structure helps, and that is
that all important process of
cell division when the DNA needs
to be copied and sent to
the next generation.
With 22,000 genes, that's
a bit of a mess.
But instead if the genes are on
chromosomes, the job gets a
lot simpler.
So if we're partitioning out
these chromosomes between
daughter cells, we keep one
Chromosome One there, send the
other one to a new cell, keep
one Chromosome Two, send the
other to a new cell, and the
same thing for the other
chromosomes.
So instead of having this big
messy job to do, we've got a
comparatively simple
job to do.
So this accurate and faithful
copying of DNA has carried
this genetic information from
generation to generation right
through all living organisms.
And you could say that this
is the secret of life.